يبحث عن حلول هنا ازمه تكاد تفقده البصر
الدواء ينعدم في تونس والمعتاد بات مشوشا
قلت عايش كنت نقراك حتى وقت الفراغ
الحاجات البسيطه اللي انا كنت تروح الراهب
بسيطه حاجات
يبحث عن انفراجه في الخارج بعد انعدام
الادويه في الصيدليات علاجات رفعت الدعم
عنها تدريجيا وانعدمت بعدها الى ان اصبحت
اليوم عنوانا ازمه معلقه منذ شهور
جيب وانا قلت لك
جيبه بسوق بتاع لبرا يا اخوي هم كانوا
مدعم 5500 يا خويا انا هذا صغير
النظام الصحي التونسي مثقل بالديون بنحو
30025 مليون دولار تعجز تونس عن دفع
المستحقات الماليه للمعامل الاجنبيه
المصنعه للادويه ما ادى الى تقييد تصدير
الادويه للسوق المحلي مئات الادويه اللي
هي مش موجوده في سوق تونسيه المشكله هذه
معناتها الادويه من جميع الاصناف
اصناف متعدده خطر المخابر العالميه تخدم
جميع الاصناف والاصناف هذه الكل اذا كان
ثم حد من التزود في تونس بشكل يسير الحد
في جميع الاصناف
وشحوا العلاجات المزمنه فتح الباب امام
تبادل غير رسمي للادويه فمن لديه دواء غير
مستخدم يمكنه ان يفصح عنه فالدواء هنا
مقابل اخر غذاء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات